so Kellan Lutz the dude from Twilight
plays Hercules in this movie
[Music]
[Applause]
that is not G oculus he doesn't even
look like me what is the name of the
demon later who gave him permission to
pretend to be Hercules oh yeah January
is still here it's still roaring and
we've got the legend of Hercules to
prove it Thank You Hollywood I hate you
continuing in the recent trend to have
two of the exact same movies in the same
year last year we had two white house
movies Olympus has fallen in white house
down this year we have the legend of
Hercules this movie and then the
Hercules movie with the rock directed by
Brett Ratner coming out later this year
after seeing this film I am really
looking forward to the Brett Ratner
version that's telling me something this
movie's directed by Renny Harlin you may
recognize that name from the director of
die hard 2 or the long kiss goodnight he
also has made a lot of really crappy
movies like cutthroat island and 12
rounds and he doesn't really do anything
good anymore let's just put it that way
in regards to the subject material this
movie is covering Greek mythology this
is one of the worst movies in that genre
I have ever seen this is a laughably bad
movie there was a scene early on in the
movie where you're really supposed to
care with his characters crying so hard
about this thing and I was laughing and
I was like I don't care I am laughing at
this there were only like four other
people in the thursday-night ten o'clock
showing they didn't seem to mind I
thought it was hilarious this movie is
horrible the acting is so atrocious this
guy Kellan Lutz might be a nice guy in
real life but as an actor this just
proves once again that most of the
people that have come out of that
Twilight series they can't act worth
crap he's so bad this movie that if you
actually go and watch the trailer for
this movie he barely speaks a line of
dialogue in the entire trailer because
the editor in the studio was like yeah
this isn't good the green screen in this
movie was so incredibly awful that I was
actually in disbelief there was one shot
early on in the movie where the girl
looks behind her she looks behind her
when she's riding a horse it looked like
a 1965 James Bond movie and it looks
some of the old James Bond movies are
fantastic for their time but if the
green screen in your movie that comes
out in 2014 looks like the skiing scene
and on Her Majesty's Secret Service
you've got a problem my friend everyone
in this movie screams and everything
people are just sitting around talking
and they're like yeah why Lister day
hey my day was good
I killed a bear it was like they just
kept trying to force all this
testosterone in this movie so you didn't
actually feel like you're watching a
bunch of manly people just a bunch of
people with big muscles ago the romance
in the movie is hysterical everyone in
this film looks like an idiot the
clothing it's terrible it doesn't look
like it's worn in or anything but for me
the most unforgivable thing about this
movie is it's a complete ripoff of 300
and gladiator it is the most obvious
copy of those movies it has that same
stupid slow-mo speed-up slow-mo speed-up
action style that 300 had it was kind of
cool and stylistic in that movie and it
wasn't as overused at that point at this
point in cinema were like stop doing
that no one cares if a guy jumps in the
air and goes if you enjoy that type of
movie have fun with this movie it's so
terrible I laughed throughout a large
majority of this movie and for the other
part of it I wanted to fall asleep this
is what I do every January I just keep
taking it in the book talks guys the
legend of Hercules is not a movie you
should be seeing it is for sure an F I
hated it don't waste your time with this
movie don't even think about it again
just just let it just delete it from
your mind that's what I'm gonna do until
December when I bring it up again and my
worst of the year list cuz I guarantee
it's gonna be on that one thanks very
much for watching guys and as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mint iced
[Music]